we are told that fifty-two times seven
hundred and sixty two is equal to thirty
nine thousand six hundred and twenty
four and then we're told to match each
expression to its product and these
products this is the exercise on Khan
Academy you can move them around so the
product can be matched to the
appropriate expression so pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
alright now what you might have realized
is all of these expressions deal with
the same digits as fifty two times seven
hundred and sixty two they just have the
decimal in different places and so what
we can do is we could say hey look the
answer is going to have the digits three
nine six two four in that order and you
could see all of these have the digits
three nine six two four in that order
and then we can estimate what these
expressions should be equal to what the
product should be equal to to think
about the decimal so this first
expression zero point five two times
seventy six point two the way I think
about it is zero point 5 - that's close
to 50 hundredths that's close to 1/2 and
so seventy six point two that's close to
seventy six and so this first expression
this first product should be roughly
half of seventy six half of seventy six
would be around thirty eight and so
which of these is close to 38 well this
first one is thirty nine point six two
four so that's actually the closest of
38 the second one is 396 and then we
have 3962 so I like this first one the
thirty nine point six two four that
feels right now the second expression is
zero point five two times seven hundred
and sixty two well once again zero point
five two is roughly equal to fifty
hundredths roughly equal to five tenths
roughly equal to one half and so and
seven hundred sixty two we could say hey
you know that's if we want to be really
rough really really approximate it we
could say hey it's roughly eight hundred
and so this should be about half of
eight hundred so it should be around
four hundred and so we actually had that
choice already there so this would be
three hundred ninety six point two four
it definitely wouldn't be the three
thousand nine hundred sixty two point
four and so I'm already feeling good
this last choice sits down here but I
can verify it 5.2 well let's just say
that's roughly five 762 let's say that's
roughly eight hundred so five times
eight hundred that would be around that
would be four thousand and so we would
express we would expect this expression
to be close to four thousand and indeed
that's what this choice is so it turns
out that it was already in the order
that we need it to be but it's good that
we checked on that